this is Jocko podcast number 184 with
echo Charles and me Jocko Willick good
evening echo good evening it's been a
while since we've done some QA and
there's been a lot of questions so let's
get into it ready to go into it okay
question number one Jocko I'm having
issues playing the game quote/unquote at
work I'm quiet and friendly but I prefer
to work hard rather rather than stand
out and talk I found I have trouble
forming more personal connections with
my boss and coworkers
what are your tips so look when I talk
about playing the game I'm not talking
about the fact that you have to change
your entire personality profile to start
to connect with people that's not what
I'm saying you don't have to go from
being someone that's what they say quiet
and friendly you don't have to become
some chatty extrovert running around
making small talk with anybody and on
top of that there's a little bit of a
statement here that says you know I'd
rather work hard as if there's these are
mutually exclusive things which they are
certainly not so this being forming
relationships with people and playing
the game does not interfere with your
work at all I'm not saying that you sit
around and talk when there's work to be
done
but there's gonna be natural breaks in
whatever you're doing there's gonna be
moments where skip the action pauses and
you get a chance to connect with
somebody so that's fine so so what are
some tips that how would you do this so
I thought about this of you want to
start with something small
right but you want to engage this is the
key point I don't just want to throw
something at you I want to talk at you
and besides when it's much easier just
to let someone talk about themselves so
the one I'm what my advice in this
particular question is is to tell them
something about yourself like something
minor about yourself but then that kind
of ties into something that you can ask
them mm-hmm and then they can talk to
you because most people like to talk
about themselves so you ask them a
question about themselves and then you
go so you know something something maybe
something slightly related to work so
it's not just some random statement that
you're making you know you'd say you
know what we did it yesterday at work
here reminded me of something great
reminding me of something else and then
maybe it reminded me of a movie mm eh
you know what we were doing yesterday
reminded me of this movie have you seen
that movie mm-hmm and at least you're
gonna get well no because I don't watch
a lot of movies or no I haven't seen
that movie or oh I've seen that movie
it's a popular movie but chances are
they're seeing it you know what I mean
and all of a sudden you've got a little
bit of a conversation going and that's
all we're looking for we're not looking
to turn into like chatty catty mm-hm
we're just trying to build build
relationships with people so you know
who they are so they know who you are
that's what we're talking about nothing
crazy
start small build from there mm-hmm yeah
pretty straightforward yeah in and
through that building process what I
kind of found is one and I guess maybe
this is a little tactical thing you can
kind of throw out whenever but you know
and you know when people give you advice
or they tell you something about
themselves that's something I don't know
whatever whatever the story is right and
maybe some strategy they used to do X Y
Z can be super small if you let them
know that you remembered like in the
future later on when you zoom again you
say I remembered what you said last week
you know I in this yen just say oh it
can be the smallest a purple belt
jujitsu mental jujitsu I like it it give
me the smallest thing and it just makes
you feel good so that that person will
just essentially feel more open with you
they're like oh my gosh this guy really
pays attention to me oh yeah
makes him feel valuable all that stuff
just on that small level you know so as
far as building little relations
I'd say that's a cool thing to kind of
remember to do if he can't I said it's a
cool kind of thing to remember too
proved next question Jocko may I ask
your advice for addressing a cowboy
quote unquote mentality among teams
working in dangerous environments
how would you shift a culture to kill
complacency to aggressively identify and
mitigate risk as a point of professional
pride okay this is something that we'll
definitely saw in the SEAL Teams seen
all the time in the civilian sector
you know construction companies power
companies companies where people are
doing dangerous work right policing
firefighting anything anything that has
any element of danger
you definitely see this and like I said
certainly still in the SEAL Teams too
and the answer to this is a common
answer for many leadership situations is
you have to explain why so let me put it
in a little context what you have to do
is you have to say hey let me explain to
you what happens when someone gets hurt
or injured on this job okay first of all
we get the loss of that person on the
job the the job that we're working on
the project that we're working on it
falls back there's paperwork that has to
be filed which by the way the paperwork
hurts the progress of our project as
well our budgets impacted because now we
got to bring someone else on board we
gotta train them we we take a
reputational hit as a company right what
what kind of what kind of a company
can't do a job without getting someone
hurt right I mean this isn't a high bar
it's not a very high bar to say hey can
you complete this task without getting
someone injured yeah and all of a sudden
we got a G we gonna hey you know what
our company we don't we had a lot of
people hurt well what does that tell you
about the company
it's a reputational hit who are you
gonna hire you're not gonna hire the one
that's got people getting hurt all the
time mm-hmm so there's that the and what
does that do what does that do to your
reputation in terms of everything else
because if your get a bunch of people
hurt how can I expect you to keep your
timelines how can I expect you to stay
on budget so it's those things it's
those that kind of reputation that you
get if you are getting people hurt and
then also what does it do what is it
hey about your team if you got people
getting hurt and again this is what I'm
talking as a conversation that you're
having with the group with the team
you're saying look what kind of a team
are we if we got people getting hurt
what does that say about us it says
we're Lac laksa basically it says we're
complacent it says we don't pay
attention what does it say about our
leadership if we got a guy's getting a
herd what does that say about our
leadership says we don't care about our
people which by the way it says we don't
care about our people it means it says
we don't care about our job and says we
don't care about our reputation says we
just don't damn care mmm and what does
it say about you the individual well you
know what it says about you an
individual if you get hurt you know what
it says about you
you're a knucklehead and you got hurt
you couldn't follow the procedures you
didn't follow the procedures you thought
you were smart and you got complacent
now you got hurt so these are the things
with when I talk about explaining why
those are where I'm gonna start and how
I'm going to explain and connect the
dots so that the purse the individual
see that someone getting hurt is
actually the least professional thing
that you can do from a leadership
perspective if I let one of my guys get
hurt um that's just that's just Lilly's
professional thing I can do from an
individual contributor perspective if
I'm getting hurt guess what I I didn't
follow procedures okay look
are there accidents that happened yes
there are but what I'm saying is if you
get a an accident that could have been
prevented that should have been
prevented and I as an individual let it
happen that is absolutely my fault it's
like when you got a guy getting ready
for an MMA fight and they get cut hmm
they won't learn headgear and it's like
look I get it but that was dumb and I've
had that happen I mean I've had it
happen with my fighters I've seen it
happen all cuz it happens in the UFC all
the time right
you got a fight coming up you're gonna
fight for the title for the UFC title
you're gonna make possibly millions of
dollars you're gonna be the champion of
the world Oh
two weeks out got a cut got a cut on my
head yeah babe you know blew out my ACL
do and takedown defense right look I get
it accidents happened but what was
really happy
right at that moment was it a random
accident or we were doing something that
we shouldn't have been doing so if we
start to lean towards look having
accidents is actually a an
unprofessional thing to do it's a weak
thing to do it's a bad thing to do when
we let it happen it hurts everyone not
just the individual involved that's the
attitude that we we kind of come with
you know had the in the in the Navy you
have like alcohol programs so hey this
is our program for you know alcohol
here's how we're trying to combat having
the people have alcohol-related incident
and when I was at raid at they had
someone come in to like give us a talk
about alcohol and then and then when
they got done the the guy says okay you
know sir I was the guy in charge he goes
what's your alcohol policy and I didn't
have one and I didn't have one and I was
like okay hey cool I'll come up with one
here's the alcohol policy if you get
hurt or sorry if you get drunk and you
can't if you get drunk and you get in
trouble or you get in a fight or you get
arrested or you get a DUI and you take
time away from being deployable you are
doing al Qaeda's job for them
there's the alcohol policy so now all of
a sudden it's not like hey cool we're
we're like rah rah no offices hey man do
we want to help the enemy by taking
ourselves off the battlefield there's
nothing more that al Qaeda wants then
for this seal to be arrested for DUI and
non-deployable yeah you just did Al
Qaeda's job for you yeah so that's the
kind of thing that I'm gonna build the
culture around yeah and that's the same
thing you can do with people that are
have that cowboy bent ality you shift it
so that that cowboy mentality becomes
the thing that hurts our reputation that
hurts our that hurts the company
reputation and it hurts our individual
personal reputation yeah as a man I
couldn't even prevent my my ship
from getting and from having it someone
get injured yeah so that's what I did
you did like it feeds into their
professional pride especially when you
use the word unprofessional oh yeah you
do what you're doing on that one
and then on the flipside if you say
consummate professional right oh that's
a good one if yeah if you're man you
could do it doesn't even matter the job
you can have your own lawn mowing
business when you're 13 years old
mmm if you're someone says hey that guy
that kids a consummate professional
you're like hell yeah hell yeah yeah I'm
gonna have to push back a little bit I
don't know if there's too many I don't
know if there's too many situations
where you would say a 13-year old lawn
mower now we know that mark the way the
warrior kid is heavily involved in lawn
mowing with marks meticulous mowing yes
yes sir he is but even I don't even know
if I'd call him a consummate
professional I wouldn't either but if
you if you were just working towards it
if you were to do so mark would feel
really good if you said that's what I'm
saying is you can't be just throwing
words around yeah that's okay so you
can't just throw around consummate
professional about moans yeah now let's
say the guy was a greenskeeper like on a
golf course now that person could be a
consummate professional because he's got
to dial stuff in and then maybe I guess
you get to a certain level of just
straight landscaping where oh you know
what there was a water there was a pipe
exploded Oh
Jaco came in he had that whole thing
Reese odd and reseeded took him for
hours that guy is a consummate
professional so I guess I'll take it
back well I'm just saying reserve it
resilient don't play with it okay don't
play with that flying that thing right
yeah make sense well the man that that
was very clever on your part when you
said you're doing al Qaeda's job for you
because think about it I mean you know
there's nothing worse for a guy in the
military but is you are actually helping
the enemy right now yeah and then how
you say it like you name names you know
it's not like you said the enemy which I
get that's good too but it's way better
to be like you're doing and you name
because JP will say that too right where
he'll be like um there was a sign or
something about a sign or maybe he'll
just say it'll be like you're your enemy
thanks you for not giving 100% today
Yeah right remember that one and it's
good that's a good one and it sounds
cool to get it but it is real general so
you hear that 10 times or every day or
whatever you like okay cool
it sounds cool but it won't really
affect your professional pride all the
time something too doesn't it but if you
name the enemy you know like if you have
some adversary you know and they thank
you that person whatever John Smith you
know for not giving huh you know it
might feed into you so you saying al
Qaeda thanks you you know for getting
arrested so I'm like yeah man think
about it from the flipside right what if
you think of like an al Qaeda fighting
team right and one of them gets cut like
one of their effective fighters gets
caught
I don't know doing something that they
don't like gambling but in a strip club
I don't know whatever and they say hey
you're not allowed to fight anymore for
us so he gets like exiled or whatever
whole that's sweet yeah we want them to
do that we send them some strip club
recommendation you see them saying so
it's literally you're literally doing
that
yeah literally yeah that's good all
right next question
hi Jocko you answered a question about
complainers and said you would listen to
the because well it should be listen to
them right yes you said you would listen
to them because you can learn what the
problems are I like it and people like
to be heard but how do you handle
chronic complainers the type of people
who become cancerous I'm huge fan X
extremely should take thanks for your
time
yeah this this is the cause once again
for my favorite my favorite general
remedy in in leadership situations as
you take this person and you put him in
charge but if in charge yeah and this is
one of those classic things where
someone says hey why are we even doing
it this way and you say oh echo you
don't like that cool why don't you come
up with a plan and you go execute it
however you want
yeah and and that does one or two things
either they
say okay and they step up and then they
have to figure out how hard the job the
task is and they have to get it done and
it's they learned from it and they get
humbled by it and they recognize the the
the the burden of responsibilities that
a leader actually has which is all good
or they just say no no no and they stop
complaining because they don't want to
get to a survey now what you gotta be
careful with a lot of these answers that
I give you could go like in the wrong
direction so what I mean by that is echo
says handled like we'll do the way we're
doing this and I go okay well then
you're in charge
you're gonna mean I do it like that it's
a punishment it's unitive thing that
isn't absolutely not what I'm talking
about I say you know what echo you're
pointing out some good stuff you're
point out some definite shortfalls in
the way that this is happening I'll tell
you what why don't you actually just
take responsibility for this and you can
run this task and you can make this
happen because I think you know just
based on some of the things you've
pointed out already I'm not even calling
them complaints based on some of the
things you pointed out already I think
you could probably improve upon our
process quite a bit mmm-hmm you know so
you got to be careful I'm not talking
about being a jerk to someone yeah I'm
talking about action and this is the
thing it's like it's like there's
there's there's this thing what I'm
doing I'm not just playing the game you
ever you ever told this in jujitsu I'm
like hey if you want to set me up with
the choke so that you can get my arm you
have to actually do the choke you have
to actually apply the pressure if you
don't apply the pressure I'm not
defending it my arms not gonna go where
you want it you have to actually do it
and if I don't defend it the way you
expect me to then you just choke me
yeah it's the same thing here I'm not
saying you just say well why don't you
do it then no you have to actually say
hey listen I think this is what's going
on I think you have some good points why
don't you take lead on this and and
we'll see if you can you know remedy the
situation because I think you got a
pretty good chance of doing it yeah this
isn't I'm not doing this as a punitive
thing I'm doing it cuz it's the best
thing for the team you've got a
legitimate complaint you've got a bunch
of them yeah let's get you in a position
where you can store some of those things
out yeah
so yeah so that's that's that when you
get people that are complaining you know
first of all hear them out and maybe
that's good enough right
hey listen to him and and and and once
again I'm not saying you listen to him
while your brain is elsewhere and you're
not saying but you actually listen to
what they're saying you're engaged you
really do go for the choke go for it
listen to what they're saying maybe
there's some solutions you can come up
with but then if that doesn't work and
even after they even after you listen to
them and you explain to them why things
aren't the way they want they still want
to complain it complain about it cool
that's fine
awesome why don't you take lead on this
and that way you can sort out some of
these issues appreciate it kind of like
leap said that one time it's kind of
hard to complain about a plan when it's
your plan yeah that is the truth yeah
make sense god I'm so stupid yeah this
plan sucks that I came up with but the
yeah the chronic complaining because you
could kind of I mean people complain a
lot you you you it's easy to be like oh
they're chronic complainers right but if
there's constantly will say chronic
problems that might induce chronic
complaining I'm not saying that's the
case obviously because I know there is
such thing as chronic complainers 100%
but at the very least like I you say oh
yeah put them in tried to something or
or listen to them and they'll point you
know listen to what they're complaining
about or whatever and you might actually
get turned on to all these solvable
problems you know and if you do if look
if you make someone take lead in in a
situation right and you know how it's
kind of like that's got that concept of
like taking an extreme ownership and
then what if they do like say yeah it is
your fault and then you get all mad you
know kind of thing it's like oh so you
didn't really do that it's like so if
you put someone else in charge of
something you're really putting them in
charge yeah like what if they run what
if they take lead and they solve all the
problems and it's awesome right yeah
exactly right so you don't treat this
action or this discourse as like
something to get back at the unplanned
it's not it's not just a setup yeah it's
a real move the real deal yeah and you
know that's you just use made this point
that I made which is
one of the best leadership tools that is
completely overlooked by people all the
time is very very simple to do and
that's just to listen to what people are
saying I know it sounds crazy but I've
run into all the time
leaders in all kinds of levels all kinds
of situations and the biggest problem
they have is they don't even listen to
anyone else they won't listen
yeah so when you're in a leadership
position try this be quiet and listen to
what people are saying listen to what
they're complaining about listen to what
suggestions they have listened to what
advice they give listen to their
recommendations listen just listen
sometimes you're gonna be in a much
better spot yeah and even like you
saying that out loud sounds real obvious
you know but it's man it's not cuz even
a lot of times like if you don't listen
and think of myself like all that many
trillions trillions of times that I
haven't listened when I should have most
time most of the time will say I don't
mean to not listen I don't mean to be
like it's not like I'm like hearing
noise and being like oh you don't know
what you're talking about you're dumb
you know what you say doesn't mean
anything it's not that it's more that
I'm like focused so hard and what I'm
thinking or my way or whatever like I'm
just so just of course naturally it's
mine I've been thinking about it for
years now you know kind of thing so I'm
so basically dug in to myself on my own
thing that I'm not and I'm just not
paying attention that much you know I'm
like working so hard and down this
tunnel that like I can't look out of the
tunnel kind of thing so you don't really
mean to but when you're in the situation
it's like it's not that easy you know
it's it's and you know what it is
also it's detachment yeah right because
when you're talking you're talking yeah
step back detach listen to what people
are saying I do this all the time and do
this all the time it's such a it's such
an easy move yeah let me move you just
watch you just listen even like in
jujitsu you do this you're like well the
person wants to move around a bunch :
let them move around
let's see where they're going I'm just
gonna listen to their moves you know
yeah and that's a good way to put it man
just listen to their moves just listen
and yeah if even if you primarily focus
on that list in
then like you habitually be able to do
it way better because like again like
back to the it's not like a you're not
doing it with malicious intent you know
you're not shutting them down it's
almost like you every like interrupters
right you know chronic interrupter you
interrupt me all the time some of the
time a lot of them whatever we'll say
half of the time estimate there it
doesn't feel like they're doing it
because they don't want to hear what you
have to say sometimes it's that for sure
but sometimes they it's almost like it's
almost like they have this tone of like
ding I don't think I finished my point
as good as I wanted to
almost it's them for themselves because
they're so committed to their message
and what they've been thinking the whole
time and if you're not signing right on
to it it's man I must not have set it
clear enough you see them saying I had
to like tighten up my kids on just
straight they just wouldn't let each
other talk it just interrupt interrupt
interrupt and I think it was yeah it was
my son for sure
and he looked at me and he goes he's
like he says dad you mean teachers to be
aggressive our whole lives and now all
of a sudden you're telling us just a sit
back did you tell them that that's the
dichotomy I said that's the economy all
right next question what is what is the
most important issue you've ever changed
your mind about this is you know this is
one of those things where I'm I'm sure
this is one of those questions where I
should have like some answer about some
specific subject or something you know I
mean like I can see I know what answer
is desired I know what type of answer is
desired but the reality is you know for
me taking ownership of things right this
and this this wasn't really like a I
changed my mind
mm-hmm to where what I used to say I'm
gonna blame everyone and then almost
said you know what that's not the right
policy to have I need to tart to extreme
ownership yeah I didn't do that but it
was just a thing that built and
developed inside my brain and I think
it's the most the most important thing
that I've ever sort of
recognized or conclusion that I've come
to that's not a change but I'm sure at
some point my attitude wasn't like I'll
just take ownership of that which it is
now but at some point you know I'd say
well that's not really my responsibility
right of course I know that's that's a
natural thing to say and I'll tell you
what the next and this is interesting
but the the other and this one's kind of
more of a more of a I can pin it down a
little bit closer to an answer that
someone would like and this is once
again it's gonna be a little bit a
little bit strange but the other thing
is the dichotomy of leadership and this
is that this is the thing about the
dichotomy of leadership and I actually
was thinking I actually didn't didn't
really recognize this until the last
muster hmm and I was as I was thinking
about the dichotomy of leadership maybe
he's off of a question maybe I think it
was actually before no actually was
before we even started I was just like
reviewing notes and thinking about the
dichotomy of leadership and and one of
the most important things about the
dichotomy of leadership is that if the
reason that the kind of the reason that
I came to the conclusion the reason that
I got to the dichotomy of leadership
well in getting there let me rephrase
that in getting to a point where I said
there's a dichotomy of leadership what I
had to do was I had to admit to myself
that I was wrong about everything that's
what I had to do in order for the for
the idea of the dichotomy of leadership
to to to escape my brain to get out to
get to to become a full thought what I
had to do I I had to admit to myself
that I was actually wrong about
everything
hmm so I'll give you real easy examples
one of my things that I used to tell
guys all the time you got to be
aggressive you got to be aggressive
that's how you gotta be
in order for the dichotomy of leadership
I had to admit you know what sometimes
being aggressive doesn't work hmm I used
to say you know what as a leader you
gotta stand up you got to be loud and
then I realized you know what there's I
see leaders that are too I had to admit
that I was wrong about that that
sometimes that was wrong
I had to admit that I was wrong about
keeping things simple like hey you know
what this is one of the most fundamental
laws of combat you got to keep things
simple hmm and then I had to admit that
sometimes people keep things too simple
even this fact right here right in order
to admit that I was wrong I had to be I
had to be humble and I used to preach
and I still preach humility as being
like the most important thing but guess
what there are people and there are even
me
well there's people there's times and
places where you can be too humble
yeah and so this idea this idea that
there's a dichotomy to everything it's
something that the the original thought
for me was it came from me having
one-sided opinion and then realizing
that and I'm I'm almost positive I don't
remember crystal clear but I'm almost
positive that the original thought that
I realized there was a dichotomy too was
being aggressive and and again this was
this is all kind of coming to fruition
as I'm teaching guys at trade at and
Lafe was running the junior officer
training course and I used to give them
the sole and I remember right and you
know I remember that saying myself you
know what I gotta tell guys that they
can go too far with being aggressive and
they can go too far with barking orders
and they and I just it like that's where
it came from
and if I wouldn't have been able to
change my mind right because that's what
this question was changing my mind about
something the biggest thing probably
ever in my life was understanding that
just about every characteristic that a
person can have that a leader can have
can go too far and can become a negative
characteristic so that's probably the
biggest thing that I've changed my mind
on hmm
yeah that aggressive one that makes
sense cause like yeah aggressive being
aggressive like is one of the more
effective ways to straight-up quell get
things done for sure do it it'll be done
do it you know don't wait or hesitate
yeah yeah yeah oh there's a there's a
problem in a building let's sit back
can wait until that problem source no
like you got to be aggressive
yeah but then if you're and you teach
you all kinds of lessons like this where
if you're gonna spring a trap on
somebody or something animal person
whatever what's the best type of type of
person that you can catch with a trap
probably an aggressive one you know like
they can set themself up to get trapped
if they're like aggressive you know like
an animal who's real hungry you know
yeah hesitating like different animals
like hesitant you know just hesitant
maybe sees things develop a little bit
before they take aggressor you know
certain action or whatever it'd be
harder to travel yeah generally yeah and
this is the thing that's this is what
makes humility important is it's hard to
come to grips with the dichotomy of
leadership because if you don't have the
humility to sometimes say you know what
you're right that you know what I'm
wrong yeah this is the this plan isn't
what I thought it should be yeah so hard
to do that that's why it's hard to
really get a grip on the dichotomy a
leadership and that's what makes it so
important that's what makes it the
answer to so many questions and
sometimes people will come like you know
a smoke come up and say they'll have
their power point to what I'm saying
mm-hmm
and I'll tell you right now let's let me
think of a situation where you have to
provide a counterpoint if I somebody
comes to me and says you know what being
aggressive isn't always good sometimes
if you're aggressive all you do is you
you run to your death
now an egotistical Jocko would say
negative you're wrong I'm right and I
would dig in in that position mm-hmm and
when you dig in and position you can't
maneuver anymore so I'm actually stuck
so this is a classic thing to do also
when when when I'm arguing with somebody
if you come to me and you say I think we
should do this
you know method B I say I don't say no
because I think we should do it method a
that's what I think and you think we
should do it method B you come to me I
think we should do
method B I think you're wrong you know
you know what I say okay well I think
you got some good points on method B mmm
oh all of a sudden you know all of a
sudden we're we're in a totally
different scenario yeah I just totally
flipped the script on you and I you know
what I say as I said you don't have some
good points that you have if you watch
people debate if it's really a little
slick move but you don't see politicians
do it because they're so dug in they
they can never think they're wrong yeah
and they can never and what they also
are afraid of they're afraid if they
admit they're wrong about something
they'll look yeah whereas if they said
you know what that's a good point that's
actually a good point I'm gonna need
consider that I've never really thought
of that viewpoint before you know what
I'm going to assess that but I guess I
think you guys I think there's some
validity to what you just said when's
the last time you heard a politician say
that I don't never I don't think and
then what happens is in this day and age
the the supporters of that politician
they don't they don't they don't
recognize the valid point either yeah
it's just oh yeah so we get people that
aren't thinking and - and and it's very
hard to hold dichotomies in your head
that this can be right and that can be
right there's an aggressive approach and
there's a non aggressive approach
there's a direct approach there's an
indirect approach and both of them can
be functional it's really hard to get
get a grip on that and yet it's the
answer to so many questions it's the
answer to the person either subordinate
that comes to you and says we should not
be doing it this way if your reaction
isn't two diametrically opposed what
they're saying but instead to actually
take their side and say well I agree
with you've got some really good points
let's see how this would play out talk
me through it
look at you can't even though you're
like wow you get you know you know it's
like it's like an E second it's like a
move here's I could do G to move and it
works yeah hmm so there there are some
things I've changed changed my mind on
about my mind is open though I will
change my mind if if
new evidence presents itself I'll change
my mind in a heartbeat you let's do it
present me with new evidence you what
about like um well I would think anyway
after kind of thinking about it where
yeah you I think I think generally
speaking we do kind of respect someone
who can who can change their mind and we
all see it once people's digging into
their opinion you know and saying all
kinds of weird wacky stuff to try to
defend yourself themself and you're like
that so we're talking about kind of
thing you see it it's clear so like it
seems obvious like yeah you should
change your mind one or at least open up
your mind and like I said um I'll give
that some consideration I'll look into
it and if you're right shoot I think
you're right I think that's a better way
to do it or whatever whatever the case
is but the and then I guess technically
this is a dichotomy to where you can't
do that too much because if you're
always changing your mind with it you
know like it like I don't know step
politicians yeah yeah every time the
opposing view or some other view comes
in you're like dang I didn't look at it
like that or I didn't maybe I'll look
back nor look into that more was it yes
and again and again it's like Brad does
this guy know anything because guess
what you're talking about
what there's a dichotomy yeah and if you
go too far and you change your opinion
all the time and then you become
indecisive and so that doesn't work but
if you're so if you're the other side of
the spectrum and you're completely dug
in and you never change your mind that
doesn't work either where you need to do
what do you need to do you need to
balance that economy's the dichotomies
between being flexible and inflexible if
you become ultra flexible where you're
just going with whatever anyone's saying
that's not good yeah you need to find
the middle ground that's what the
dichotomy in leadership is yeah but it's
hard for people to comprehend that yes
hard for people to see that where they
draw that line yes that is they think
well you know I'll never change my
opinion on this okay yeah you just told
me where you stand
yeah not sure I like that very much
because new new information can come to
light yeah yeah that's true
yeah that's where that where they stand
right in that dichotomy or whatever
because I think part of part of it and
it's part of it is like yeah they don't
wanna be wishy-washy you know but the
other part or the other part of that
is I'm saying if they always change
their mind and they're so easily to be
like okay maybe we'll do it your way
whatever Harper yeah it I think they
come off like they don't know anything
for sure like to the so if you don't
know anything should you even be in that
position like I don't want you to be the
congressman if you're if you don't know
anything kind of thing right that's the
feeling so and now with that that's the
feeling that people are trying to avoid
when they dig in yeah you don't wanna
admit they're wrong cuz if I admit I'm
wrong that means what I didn't know you
know kind of thing so it's like no Brad
you don't you don't draw you the line
right there you draw draw the line
couple steps down the road be open a
little bit yourself some room to
maneuver yeah next question how does one
detach when getting personally attacked
and take extreme ownership with false
claims and what does one do once when a
subordinate always goes above the chain
of command instead of working out issues
with the coworker okay I'm this isn't
the clearest question that I've ever
received I'm gonna try and I'm not sure
if I completely understand it but I'm
gonna try and sort of answer to the best
of my ability I think what we're talking
about here is that someone is telling me
that something it's my fault and that is
a false claim is that that's the
question right I think like you're
making a false claim and saying like
this is your responsibility Jocko you
were supposed to press record and it's
false because I wasn't supposed to press
record like let's say like yeah or maybe
like record was pressed like that
there's no issue you know well then why
would why would he why would that become
a personal attack yeah yeah so the
personal attack is chokku you didn't
press record
yeah and now the question is what do i
do then because because we both know
who's in charge of pressing record here
yeah who is me okay so you're in charge
of press and record if you all of a
sudden we we are 40 minutes into a into
a podcast and we haven't pressed record
the record has button has been pressed
and all of a sudden it comes to light
and you say chuckle you didn't press
record now what this person is saying
that's a false
clean not just that's not my
responsibility it's truly not my
responsibility no I'm not factual why
should I be doing that yeah and you know
what I'm gonna say you know what I'm
gonna say yes sir I do
which is you know what it is my
responsibility because I'm here it's
primarily my voice that's being recorded
and from now on I will make sure that
that gets recorded it's my fault I will
take care of it from now on by the way
now what is your job responsibilities in
this whole podcast nothing nothing to do
if you're not pressing record you're not
nothing to do yeah so how does that feel
it doesn't feel it doesn't feel good you
don't like that mm but when I take away
that responsibility you're actually
becoming clawback from me you're gonna
say you know what actually you know it
was your fault when that happened but
you know what from now on since you
screwed it up I'm gonna take ownership
of it and you know what I say is that
cool that's awesome yeah good point
since you are over there with the
recorder and since you're a technical
guy and I'm not and there's a lot of
sense when we go with that from now on
you own it yeah I shouldn't have dropped
the ball last time you know you know so
that's that so there we go I don't it I
fix it if by the way if you don't want
responsibility back if you just say cool
yeah you press record from now on okay
cool I will yeah and then guess what
I'll start thinking about how much I
need you around here yeah cuz really
what else do you bring to the table and
they'll bill all right so that's
question number one
the question number two as far as
detaching so I don't get emotional
that's if someone is blaming me if
someone is blaming me if you start
blaming me or something I actually look
at that right out of the gate I see that
as a psychological victory for me
because because you're blaming me like
you're blaming you're not taking
ownership I already won man I already
won so there's no I'm not getting
emotional about that that's they're
blaming me because they don't have the
the wherewithal to actually take
ownership themselves I see that as a
weakness of theirs and I'm fine with it
and not that's why I don't I'm not gonna
I don't need to get emotional because
I'm sitting there going wow this person
just served me up on a silver platter
the fact that they don't want to take
ownership and they're gonna give it to
me
are you kidding me I'll take this all
day long another thing is and I've said
this before
I can't be respect I can't be
disrespected by someone that doesn't
even respect themselves yeah you don't
know zan yeah you can't just respect me
if you don't even respect yourself if
you're just you know like a bum in the
street is whether where the thing came
from you know someone that's just a you
know a drunk bum laying in his own vomit
and wants to you know look at me and say
you look good dirtbag yeah like okay
dude yeah carry on with your day yeah
that you you're not gonna affect me so
how in the same vein if how can I be
disrespected by you when you tell me you
and you blame me for something when I
realize what's happening right now is
you don't even have enough respect for
yourself to take ownership or something
yeah this is just a wind so that's the
second part of that I think the third
part of the question is a subordinate
that that goes up the chain of command
instead of working through working out
the issues with the co-worker that's
pretty pretty easy I'm not gonna solve
those problems for you oh you got a
problem down the chain of command with
your coworker your peer and you guys
aren't working it out and you want me to
solve your problem no you go figure it
out we'll come back to me the solution
now I'll do that a couple times if
eventually they can't come up with a
solution guess what I have I have a
problem I have a real problem and I will
solve it and they're not gonna like my
solution because it probably involves me
neither one of them being there anymore
mmm extreme case but what I will do is I
say okay come and read me the facts
mm-hmm do you really want me to make a
decision about this cool I'll do it but
I always felt horrible in fact I don't
even know if I ever did this going to my
boss to make a decision about something
that I should have agreed with my peer
there you know what I'd rather just for
me I'd rather say hey you know what you
wanna do it your way Aiko fine let's go
with it it's close enough you oh you
want to take the lead cool you take the
lead I'll support you no problem that's
what I'm here for I want the team to win
I know you're concerned about you I
don't know that's fine that's fine I'm
here for the team so let's do it your
way so that it works out yeah not one of
my boss and complaining that's just
ridiculous
and that's that's another one where I've
been I don't think I've ever been in a
corporate scenario but it seems like
that that's easy to see in other people
you know like where you know how like a
situation where yeah let me let let my
subordinate take lead it seems like that
could be a solid almost obvious answer
for people yeah except myself you know
like I don't I don't always point that
inward you know I'm sure there's like
people out there where it's like oh that
this will solve probably a lot of your
problems just look at it this way and do
it and do that you know let let one of
your subordinates like take lead on the
stuff and I would predict as far as that
goes that most people would be pretty
surprised I call yeah I guess I should I
should do that yeah you know at this
point so you're saying that's a it's a
pretty obvious solution once you hear it
yeah but you're also saying that it's a
difficult solution to actually execute
cuz most people put in the situation
don't remember it yeah they don't
remember to point it inwards yeah even
like literally you could be getting this
advice like right now you could be
getting this advice but hey yeah that
sounds like good advice and then they'll
go like back to work and it applies to
someone else you know it's like you
don't realize it like man I should do
that you know kind of thing yeah that's
the trouble with learning learning it's
hard to apply it yourself yeah
once again it's like jiu-jitsu you can
watch I can show you how to do it and
then you can watch me do it and then I
can move your limbs around so that you
do it and then we do a drill where we
drilled a move 20 times and then you get
into a competition and they've move is
there and you don't execute it you don't
execute it correctly because you haven't
done it enough yeah you have to do the
move kind of do them you got to do the
move next one
so I'm watching Deadliest Catch it's a
fishing show wait crab crab grabbing
shit yeah Alaskan crabs
respect so I'm watching Deadliest Catch
and a deckhand wasn't paying attention
and let too many small crabs into the
tank this is big trouble for the captain
so the kid admits his mistake and
apologizes captain you're fired
I've watched you screw up for years
what's the message here yes sir it's the
captain that fire says yes he's the
mistake and says the captain says you're
fired okay gotcha yeah yeah yeah okay so
this is this is just tells me a couple
things this tells me a few things this
tells me a lot of things right first of
all the boss watched the deckhand screw
up for years mm-hmm
my assumption is that he didn't say
anything you watch someone screw up for
years how is the deckhand going to
improve if he doesn't get counseled on
what his shortfalls are okay so that's
one that that could have happened right
that's one assumption let's make the
other assumption the other assumption is
that the the captain did counsel the
deckhand and watch him screwed up for
years and told him you better not do
that you better not do that you better
not do that and he's now done it again
and guess what he's getting fired mm-hmm
so so that that's understandable so I
think the question is implying kind of
like you know hey this yep hey boss this
was my fault you shouldn't let that
happen and now the boss can say a-hole
since you're taking the ownership of
that that's no problem we'll let it go
mm-hmm that doesn't happen
so if you have a if you have a concept
in your brain that you think that when
you when you take ownership for
something that you're immune then from
the punishment of the mistake you've
made that's not true
that's absolutely not true taking
ownership of a mistake does not relieve
you of responsibility of that mistake in
fact the opposite of true when you take
ownership of a mistake your take
ownership of the mistake and you are
raising your hand and saying I own the
mistake and if there's punishment to be
meted out it needs to land on me that's
what ownership is ownership is not a
get-out-of-jail-free card you know it's
my fault that you don't we joke about
this is my bust a my bust on that one oh
it won't happen again so now everyone
just ignores it no this is a serious
violation having the wrong size crabs is
the kind of thing to get you rolled up
by the Fish and Game Department and all
of a sudden you're getting shot down
this is a serious business hundreds and
hundreds and hundreds of thousands of
dollars if not more are at stake here
and this kid isn't doing his job
correctly
so either the boss the captain had
mentored him and was fed up which which
it makes him a good boss and this was
his last warning and he failed his last
warning and there you go hey I've been
watching you screw up I told you you
screwed up I've written you up about
screwing up and I told you not to let
this happen again and you just let it
happen again
you're fired mm-hmm or maybe the boss
wasn't that squared away and he hadn't
Council to me hadn't had the hard
conversations early with him to square
him away and now yeah the boss leaves
something to be desired because he's
just the first offense he's that he
talks him about his hey you're fired
when I took ownership of the blue on
blue an extra note in extreme ownership
first chapter I could have been fired
for that yeah I could have been fired my
boss Kerr said yeah yeah you're right
this is your fault we can't have that
happen out here you're fired
and I will you know and I said Roger
that mmm it's not hey I own this now
here I will say this though if so taking
extreme ownership is not a
get-out-of-jail-free card but I will
tell you this if you make excuses it is
going to be worst in 99% of the
situations well the small crabs snuck in
when I wasn't looking that's not my
fault
tactical craps all right then you just
look like an idiot right so then another
thing that this brings up is this idea
of pre-emptive ownership and that is
taking owned if you take ownership of
something you don't you don't want to
take ownership after the fact extreme
ownership the idea of extreme ownership
in its purest and most effective form
isn't hey something went wrong and I'm
now taking ownership of the mistake
that's not the that's not the best
extreme ownership scenario the best
extreme ownership scenario is when you
take ownership prior to the mistake
happening and you realize that if the if
there is going to be a mistake you are
going to own it so what you're gonna do
is you're gonna work hard to prevent
that mistake from happening that's
pre-emptive ownership you're taking
ownership before the mistake happens so
this kid this deckhand could have done
put procedures in place to make sure no
small crabs got it it sorted him out
properly but instead he thought well you
know would be no big deal I'll just take
ownership and then they'll say it's okay
or you know I'll blame someone else or
whatever his thinking is Brett if he
says look if I let small crabs in here I
am gonna own it and I am gonna get fired
guess what perhaps he would have worked
a little harder to prevent these small
crabs from being where they weren't
supposed to be but see when you have
that out when you think you can just
blame someone else yeah that allows you
to be slack yeah when you think well you
know this isn't really my response but
that's why when I work with companies
and they'll have some thing that's going
wrong some problem some procedure that's
not working correctly some timeline
that's not being met and one of the
first questions I ask it normally like a
huge step in the right direction to
resolve the problem is I go okay who's
in charge of that process and a bunch of
people will be looking around at each
other and no one's raising their hand
and the minute I see that I go hmm
interesting this is this is the answer
to me now we know why the process is
ineffective because no one has ownership
of it and if no one has ownership of it
and the thing doesn't get done when it's
supposed to get done
his points at each others as well no
wonder my father was his fault in her
fault and then no one takes ownership
and no one solves it whereas if you say
okay Eko
you are in charge of this process if it
doesn't work I'm coming after you you
know now you can step up your game
preemptively to prevent a mistake from
occurring prevent the little crabs from
getting in the pot yeah so taking
ownership is a get-out-of-jail-free card
if you have a subordinate you aren't
actually responsible for counseling them
and coaching them and mentoring them and
explaining to them what the standards
are so that they can meet the standards
explaining explicitly what the standards
are so that they can meet those
standards and the optimal ownership
takes place not only after but more
importantly before something goes wrong
there you go not to mention you gotta
take responsibility for solving the
problem yes you do which apparently this
deckhand guy that's not yeah he didn't
take he took ownership for the mistake
he didn't take ownership for the for
solving problem he also didn't implement
a solution to the problem there's all
kinds of four years by the way yeah so
there you go
next question what mistakes did you make
early discussed in your live podcast
that could have progressed you further
hmm yeah I think there's just some real
big obvious ones wasted a bunch of time
you know you waste a bunch of time when
you're young you think you got forever
and you waste time and whether it's
doing stuff that's not productive
whether it's going out getting drunk or
whatever dumb things you waste time
doing whether it's just just wasting
time and and you know what look I'm not
saying don't have fun in your life
because that's wrong answer to if that's
too extreme but what I am saying is I I
sometimes I had a little too much fun
sometimes I wasn't focused on the right
thing so wasted time is number one
wasted money wasted a ton of money on
dumb stuff and
I'd say that both of these are wasting
time wasting money those are like the
two biggest mistakes that I've made but
I would say that the root of those
mistakes is that I didn't do a good job
of connecting the future to the present
Yeah right
you just don't when you're young I
shouldn't say that when I wish I was I'm
gonna put a universal blanket of being
dumb on everyone even though you're
nodding your head pretty hard alee over
there probably yeah
we see a lot of people do this right a
lot of us we waste our time we waste our
money and we don't connect what we're
doing right now with what's gonna happen
in the future that is not a good policy
to have what we want to do and what I
try and instill with kids with my kids
with with kids that I talk about on the
podcast is I want to connect what
decisions are being made right now with
decisions that with the with the end
state that you end up with in your
future so if you take advantage of your
time you're gonna be in a much better
place if you save your money you're
gonna be in a much better place if you
invest your money properly you're gonna
be a much better place if you train and
you treat people if you train hard
you're gonna be in a much better place
if you treat people respectfully and you
build relationships you're gonna be in a
much better place hmm if you do the
opposite of those things you're gonna be
in a worse place if you treat people
like dirt you're gonna it'll come back
to bite you if you waste your money you
won't have it if you waste your time
you'll run out so I think the biggest
mistake really for me was that I failed
to connect the present to the future the
only ways that I succeeded in that early
on was through luck
hmm like I joined the Navy and and and
I'm very lucky that I did because I was
immediately building my future even
though I had no I it wasn't my intent
doesn't mean I bought a house that was a
great on what I wanted to what did I buy
it for I wanted a place to live what did
I end up with an incredible investment
enough to buy another house that one was
a little bit more intentional okay wait
a second if I owned another house and I
was just talking about this with a
friend of mine who was like
that I was explaining when and he
remembered when I got my second house
and I was like in my mind Donald J Trump
the real-estate landlord like master
right someone was gonna be paying me
rent you know and and I had another
house that I was gonna live it mm-hmm so
that was a that was when I started
making this shift where I connected the
present with the future yeah so what'd
you do today is directly correlated to
where you'll end up in the future that
that is in echos favorite sort of thread
of this entire podcast disser is playing
the Longmore and it took me too long to
start fighting the long war that's what
I'll say that'll say the biggest
mistakes from my early life yeah and
really in a way I mean they could be
viewed as not even really mistakes I
guess this is more of just sort of
that's the way things happen because be
most times we figure these things out
later in life be when the long game
starts to materialize because when
you're early in your career that you
only the short game is sort of there and
then in a way to actually know at the
end of the day no because even as a
little kid you know the long game you're
familiar with it a little bit because
like you ever had ever had to save your
money for something like Optimus Prime
boy you know something like that
they said you gotta save your money for
it yeah and no you save your money
you know that's playing the long game
yeah as a kid you know it's a kid
version so it's kind of same thing but
maybe it's not as intuitive you know
when you're little when you're big when
you're grown to difference it's the
other fear the weird thing is like
someone has to tell you but like we just
talked about sometimes when people tell
you you still just don't listen to them
yeah yeah you know people say hey you
should really do this and you go yeah
whatever that's for you yeah yeah yeah
it's for you one of my one of my uncle's
friends won the lottery years ago like
in the 70s
and he won one of those big lotteries
mmm where he got money every year you
know you could take the lumps on or you
could take the payments the payments
he took the payments yeah but won the
lottery right literally won the lottery
won the lottery and so the payments
lasted 20 years well when you're 22
that's that's forever Yeah right
that's forever yeah and so my dad was
talking to him talking this guy that won
the lottery and now he was at like the
nineteen year mark yeah and guess what
he had done with all this money spent
didn't he invested in real estate did he
buy start companies what do you think he
did with this money spent it yeah he
bought car and whatever that ten
thousand you know like dated girls and
went to bars and went out for nice
dinners and did that for a long time
yeah and so my my dad says hey you know
they're talking about it he says well
you know my you know this is the last
year that I'm getting my monthly
payments for winning the lottery mm-hmm
and my dad says what are you gonna what
are you gonna do when the payments
aren't coming anymore
mm-hmm and he says I'm gonna win again
yeah that's planning right yeah in a
sense we all kind of and you know it's
not obviously but man that's one the law
but that tends to go like that
for lottery winners yeah apparently the
lottery winning isn't a big like
happiness no it's bad yeah ends up being
bad because life is a long long game and
no matter how you play it the long game
is the one that that shakes out you know
so if you're over you're playing the
short game that's that's why you lose in
life if you play the short game all the
time yes and the people who play the
long game they did all you gotta do is
play it you don't even have to dominate
it although I'm not recommending not
trying to dumb and I'm not saying trying
Domino necessary after yeah you could
come in shoot second to the last place
but if you're playing the game you're
gonna be doing good it along with you
when you come in second to last place in
the long game you still just be
every single other person that's playing
the short game you know you beat them
all yeah and it's not here and they're
over there looking around like what just
happened yeah how is who you're so
squared away yeah but it's not that
complicated you know I mean it's not
easy it's not easy you're wired to
please how do you go deep on this on
that last warrior kid podcast yeah oh
yeah this this death it's like a little
short term you have need to get over the
short term gratification man and that is
the one of the biggest lessons a kid can
learn is that my actions today will
affect my future and it's hard to
convince some of that it seems so
distant you know like the future seem so
distant yeah when you're young yeah I
was having another discussion with
someone a parent and and there was a
level of frustration mm-hmm that and
it's the typical level of frustration
from the parent which was you know the
kid has a lot of potential but they're
like they do not training the way they
should be and not working the way you
know all that and all that stuff and
what I tried to explain to the parent
was that the potential that you're
telling your kid that he has they do not
even comprehend what that means it is
not a it is not a it's not something
that they can understand it it's
completely intangible like even when you
say oh you keep practicing this you
could be the champion yeah this means
you might as well say if you keep
practicing this Ebru bobbers you
probably not okay yeah yeah it means
nothing to them yeah so that's what
potential is to a little kid a little
kid doesn't understand it
yeah and so yes you try and convince him
I mean you try and explain it to him
mm-hmm but what I recommend is instead
of trying to explain to them this
massive concept of what their potential
is you try and give them some short term
rewards that lead them in the right
direction that are are supportive of the
long game but they're easier mental
connections for the kid and this the
same thing applies to employees as well
right you know or you get a young young
employee that's you know they're not
thinking they could be
the regional manager right there just
thinking they're just happy to be here
yeah but you're you're looking I'm gonna
risk you know this is sharp kid could be
could so you might not say look one day
you're gonna be the regional manager in
22 years think about that when you if
somebody gets hired on as whatever and
you say one day you're you could be the
regional manager and you could make
whatever this big chunk of money they're
looking at you go home own are gonna be
here too we don't we're gonna have this
job for six but whatever yeah so what
you want to do is just tie something a
little bit closer to them to their
reality yeah of hey here's where you
could get here's where we the bonus
program works here have you seen this
you can make an extra whatever yeah and
it's gonna move them in the right
direction long game but they can
comprehend it immediately yeah that's my
recommendation should even just
compliments and encouragement are good
little micro rewards for those
short-term like they were my kids
once again we can't abuse them yeah an
abuse you know friendliness with our
children we can abused cheerleading yeah
right we can abuse cheerleading with our
kids and everything that they do is
beautiful right yeah no that's just
beautiful yeah a piece of art that you
just created what is it no yes sir
it's like that that's not good yeah
that's not good but you're just talking
about abuse and the other thing is the
other thing you have to be careful with
this you know you're telling your kid
like well you know you're special
yeah or you're you're so perfect right
you know yeah and so you know yeah so
this can get better yeah I get your
marginal just know that no yeah and what
I mean encourage me in in in complements
it's like if they do something good you
compliment that good thing that's
essentially it
yeah like anything you can throw out too
many and you can throw out two little
really because the the fulfillment or
satisfaction of receiving that
compliment isn't big enough for the work
that they just still be like man I want
to do those 100 I mean my daughter do 90
burpees
why ninety did you just want to withhold
no I'm worth a century I'm working her
she didn't get to 90 and say hey Dad you
do whatever you want I'm getting ten
more watch this no I'm getting do a
hundo
well here's the thing she's done that
before but not with 90 so I'm working
her up
I started from like I was like a when
she was real slow more time I didn't
time it how are we gonna recognize
improvement because we're gonna get to
the number first then we go for example
got it so I mean that's the sir I mean
it's not like you know my life's mission
of course it's just a fun little thing
that I do
but if sounds fun yeah sure but so if if
I'm like hey um hey you're super strong
they like that or my kids like that when
you call them strong so every time they
do something like exercises something
like that and they do a good workout or
whatever I'll say how strong they are or
how strong they're looking or being or
whatever but if that feeling isn't
enough to constitute that super hardware
like if I over push them like a 90 given
where we are with burpees with her she's
not raised she wasn't ready for 90 at
this time so did she cry she know she
ain't cry thankfully she'll cry no shame
she'll cry I went for a run with my
youngest daughter this is a while ago
and I don't know how old she was at the
time but I was like okay we're gonna
start running cuz I wanted to improve
her mile time at the school I said okay
you wanna improve that my own time I
know how to do it
here we go so her mile time was weak and
I said we can get it better so the first
run we went on I'm not kidding
she by the time we got one minute deep
she had tears welling up in her eyes
yeah and and you know I said hey just
keep going but the the the point of
saying this is my when I try and give
children especially my children or any
children complements I try and
compliment their hard work yeah as
opposed to your strong or your smart and
what I say is you
worked hard for that and look at this
great result because what it makes them
realize is that great results come from
hard work and guess what that is the
truth because we all know people that
were incredibly smart incredibly strong
incredibly talented and incredibly
gifted and they didn't do anything with
any of those things because they didn't
understand that they had to work hard
even if you have all that skill if you
don't work hard you're not gonna get
anywhere yeah dang that's a good little
so addition lean towards complementing
the hard work yeah and that's what you
really want to see yeah let's face it
let me ask you this and this is a tough
question would you rather have someone
on your team that is extremely talented
or extremely hard worker you know of
course it's easy we all want to say well
I take the talent cuz we can make the
person work hard but that's actually not
true and and the real talent the best
talent really is you get someone that
just knows how to grind and work hard
yeah like that's good and that's gonna
be much more valuable then hey this
person super smug or hey this person
super strong occasionally you get
someone like GSP yeah George st. Pierre
who was way talented in multiple
modalities and was a hard worker you
know what that person becomes a world
champion yeah sometimes you get a world
champion that's just there because of
hard work sometimes you get a world
champion that's just there cuz of talent
occasionally you get someone that's both
and they're usually sort of a staring
more dominant yeah like a dominant jet
yeah that's true and that's good or do I
started to compliment the hard work um I
I personally like both I like the wide
especially with my son like being strong
and stuff he really likes that you know
so he'll it's to the point where like if
you help him do something he'll get mad
at you're gonna get mad
yeah which I kind of like I don't know
where that's gonna lead you know but I
like that currently um so he he has that
sense of pride you know we're being
strong is a good thing I know that's a
little is nothing wrong with that so
yeah but man if you add the hard work
part of it because being strong is so
essentially a result you know yeah
and he doesn't obviously - yeah it's
really gonna be easy connection for you
to make because it's hey you're strong
and that's cuz you work hard yeah
because the minute you say you're strong
because you got just a drone yeah cool
I'll just be sitting over here bees what
do you got yeah it's true and and when
you especially if you don't recognize
the hard work part of it you know and
you just think you're as a kid you're
just rolling around strong you're you're
basically you you've reveled in the
results for so long where it's now when
it's hard work time it's kind of like
wait I'm not used to that part they say
that can happen - they call gazelles
in Budds these are people that like
really fast good athletes yeah and but
they never lost before yeah and yes they
started getting beat down which you do
get beat down and they lose they can't
handle it mentally yeah oh yeah
so yes sir that is um that's real next
question chuckle my wife told me that
she sees I am much more direct and less
cordial than I used to be I feel I've
pushed too much into getting after it
and it makes those around me feel like
I've changed to someone else yeah we
have to be really careful right yes
because being more direct and less
cordial is definitely not getting after
it in fact is the opposite if you are
getting after it
in a correct manner your wife should be
completely stoked you know because
you're gonna have more time for her cuz
you're gonna be doing time management
properly mm-hmm you're gonna have you're
gonna be doing better at work which
means you're gonna be getting promoted
or whatever getting paid more or you
know getting job stability or whatever
something like that you're gonna be
healthier because your your work and how
you're gonna be stronger because you're
working out you're gonna be more
organized with things and you're gonna
be more thoughtful about building that's
what a getting after is you like your
your relationship should be improving
yes not this and this is one of those
this is one of Ecco Charles's favorite
things to talk about it's actually
something that you've just brought up a
bunch
on the podcast which is when someone
says no that's just how I am
look no aleko I'm just gonna tell you
the truth because that's just how I am
just making an excuse for being a jerk
coming out of the gate which is not good
so if that's what you're doing with your
wife you know what I'm just gonna get
after it
hey this tuna casserole sucks I'm just
telling you where it is that's how I
roll like no you're actually rolling in
the wrong direction when you're getting
after it in a good way
your wife will be stoked I was getting
interviewed the other day and I realized
this so I've written eight books the
eighth one comes out in January of 2020
it's a lot of writing I wrote 90% of the
words in those books while my family was
asleep then it made almost no impact on
the family hmm
I'm writing these books editing is a
little bit different cuz there's a
timeline on editing so sometimes my my
family would be awake while is editing
and I had to get stuff turned back in
and it's a pain but that's like Oh takes
a week right but the other 90% of
getting after it was done while my
family is asleep if you contrary are
getting after at the expense of your
family and friends that's not that's
actually being selfish so that's one
part okay so maybe you need to check
yourself there and make sure that you've
got your priorities in order
there is a chance however that your
friends don't like seeing you start to
get some altitude right start to be more
successful start to lead a better life
there's all kinds of groups of people
that will just drag you back down they
don't want to see you win that's sort of
I I don't know is that the fundamental
kind of baseline human instinct I don't
want to see you in if there is an
element of it too I would not be
surprised put it that way but
and there's at least a non-trivial part
of the prop ulation population that does
not want to see you win yeah there's at
least a percentage whatever that
percentage is of the people that you
know that does not want to see you in
they would rather see you fail they
would rather and maybe fails not the
word but they would at least rather have
you stay with them yeah yeah that makes
sense
so there's a chance that that's going on
is there a chance that that's going on
with your wife
hopefully not that's a slim chance
because if you think about it your
success her success is predicated on
your success I mean you are bound to
each other both each of your success is
predicated on each other's success so do
I want my wife to be successful oh yeah
because I that's my wife and she's
looking at me going yes go be successful
the more successful I am the more
successful she is so there's a there's
most likely your your wife in my opinion
would be supportive of your efforts
unless you're just getting out of
control there's a chance I guess that a
wife could see you know someone change
and you know that's not the person that
I married right but hold on the person
that you married was lazy and I'm over
here getting after it the person that
you married was making X amount of money
now I'm making a lot more than that the
person that you married wasn't in good
physical shape I'm in good physical
shape mm-hmm most of the time the wife
would say cool yeah I'm getting a better
deal now occasionally I think you would
get a spouse I guess could be the male
or the female could happen on either
side that goes oh you want to work hard
and I'm gonna really not looking to do
that I was comfortable right that I was
comfortable that's it yeah I'm
comfortable I don't want you getting all
crazy I'm over here being comfortable so
that could happen hmm
I think that's unlikely I think what's
most likely is you are focused on
yourself a little bit too much check
yourself for that that should be the
first person you look at you yeah that's
true huh because like it is actually
kind of common where
husband-wife whichever the scenario is
where one let's say let's say two people
they get married whatever years down the
road one of the people in the couple the
relationship improves themself a lot to
lose a bunch of weight there they're
literally by their own standard they
were not very attractive when they got
married but now this is ten years later
whatever they become straight-up
attractive now making more money more
people want to hang out with them
because they're nicer like all this
stuff straight up across the board
improvement mm-hmm
meanwhile the other person in the
relationship didn't do that still
married still all good no infidelity
nothing like that still married but that
person who didn't improve themselves
will feel like they got phased out or
kind of like like the person might want
to upgrade or something like that you
know so it's like it's impossible they
try and drag the person back down yeah
cuz you need to be back here I need to
be feel secure now I'm this husband and
not my wife's hi I'm not used to a hot
life because when we got married you
weren't that hot mmm I loved you for you
and you know all this stuff
and you know what they say or whatever
and um and now you're know you know I'm
thinking yeah cliche movie thing but
anyway the the wife's like all
good-looking now people were like people
at the store or like complement here and
all this stuff and the guy's not used to
it and now in his mind a little thing
develops or it's like oh oh like I'm not
good enough now for this hot girl I'm
gonna buy her some Cheetos yeah bring
her back down so like at least have some
manage you know manageable amount of
control this person that's you know
that's not an uncommon thing in that
specific scenario I guess that scenario
is not very common though it's not a
very common scenario and then it would
have to be doubly uncommon for someone
to actually want to drag them back down
I have to throw it out there though cuz
it is a possibility yeah but for this
particular question I don't think so
only because this little indicator right
here my wife told me that she sees I am
much more direct and usually much more
direct means insensitive in my
experience wives don't do good generally
speaking with insensitivity less cordial
that's another one in my opinion in my
experience
married yeah metalcore do you learn
things I'm gonna give you an example
something I learned about my wife if my
if my wife if it isn't on the schedule
it's about enough to make my wife get
mad right so in other words if I said
hey I'm going away for one a month from
now I'm going away for six months on a
work trip I'll be back when I'm done
with those six months and when I'm gone
and you're not gonna be able to hear
from you know she'd be like okay got it
when do you leave and I'd say well I'm
leaving whatever yeah
September first and she'd go okay she
wouldn't be even remotely upset she'd be
good to go yeah if it was Friday night
and I came home and said oh I'm I didn't
tell you or Saturday night I said I
didn't tell you but I'm going over to
echos to watch the UFC there's a decent
chance that she's mad about that yeah
because she had in her mind that we were
gonna eat whatever yeah we were going
out for dinner or whatever but I didn't
I didn't give the pre-planned yeah
situation what if she didn't make a plan
for that it was just sort of maybe we
could do that it's it's no it's not on
her it's on me yes on me for not
informing her of what was going on
because it doesn't really matter all she
knew is that I was coming home yeah and
I was gonna be around and that was what
was happening yeah because it would
anything that is not put you know what's
really funny this is again with my wife
and this is this is where it became
evident to me even if it's something
that is positive for my wife and if I
don't give her pre-planning cycle on on
what's gonna happen so in other words if
I was flying home and I've been her gone
for a week and I just you know got home
and busted through the door and said hey
I I'm on a tail end of a 72-hour fast
I'm starving I'm taking you out and I
made reservations for this really nice
dinner
I'm gonna go get some you know a 200
dollar stake right now
there's a chance the the the the the
percentage should be 100 percent she's
stoked right yeah that should be the
percentage however with my wife there's
a 20 to 30 percent chance that she says
you know I was gonna take you know I was
gonna take our daughter to you know the
raffle I don't know to play bingo and
like that is enough yeah and and and I
what I don't do is I say oh cool you
know what we'll go tomorrow what I don't
do is trying to impose it yeah so what
you're saying is like lack of being
cordial what I'm saying is it's not just
like that's one example of me not being
cordial so I don't I try not to I guess
I guess well I guess to sum it up my
wife doesn't really like surprises right
she likes to have a plan she likes to
know what's happening and then she'll
execute the plan so that's what you got
to be careful of you which got to be
well not what you got be careful if that
is one example of how these little
things they don't make sense it doesn't
make sense that some that my wife
wouldn't be super stoked to go out to a
awesome steak house yeah that doesn't
make sense to anyone well you know
that's a superficial thing and let me
tell you something else that makes it a
little bit tricky is I'm super
insensitive to like changing plans like
people change plans with me I'm like
whatever it's no it's literally no
factor yeah oh wait oh yeah we've been
planning to do this for six months
someone's like oh I can't do it I'm like
okay cool yeah you don't mean it's it
means nothing to me when things change
it means nothing it's I it has no impact
on me I have no emotional reaction to
someone saying hey this we can't do this
now and I'm like okay cool I'm gonna do
something else
yeah so I'm at the other end of the
spectrum yeah which means it took me a
little while to figure out that oh this
makes you mad yeah got it
you know Cheers
and it's probably probably something
like one level like under the surface -
it's not like hey I had this good you
know the raffle was was planned in my
head and that raffle is important the
raffle is not important
neither is the dinner it's like that
part of it on that level is not
important it's one level deeper it's the
fact that I had to sit my head you
didn't tell me this other thing and now
like what I had in my head really means
nothing yeah so it's kind of that here's
another funny thing about my wife is
she's so into the planning thing that if
I planned something it has way more
value to her so in other words if I say
hey when I get back this Friday mm-hmm
I'm gonna do a fast and I'm gonna be
super hungry I'm gonna make reservations
for this Friday right and we can go out
and get an awesome steak you know
tomahawk rib eye and like the fact that
it was pre-planned like I've done this
before where I'm taking her and I've
gotten reservations and she'll be like
did you make reservations and I'll say
yes I yeah I did and I can see like a
little smile like I care a little bit
more that I made those reservations like
that's pretty what what the spontaneity
thing
no does no no no points for spontaneity
zero zero points respond any only points
for pre-planned fires you know why why
good it's thoughtful yeah exactly
yes yes yeah that's great that's good
that's good that's an interesting
quality right there and I guess my point
in saying this this these things mmm is
that everyone has these little
personality traits people you work with
people your your spouse your children
they have these things and if you figure
out what those things are you can
actually utilize them to your advantage
and you can bypass things that will be
problematic and something that you've
said - is you say oh you do this stuff
to me meaning jhaqo
does you
do some like leadership trick to you you
know that I'm doing it yeah but it's
still like it works and it still makes
you feel the way that you know it's
supposed to make you feel that's my
point like my wife will listen to this
yeah and it's and then I'll make
reservations and she'll still be here
even though that she knows that I'm
doing it just because I know that it's
going to be something that makes her
happy yeah yeah so just because you
reveal like hey I know this is what
you're like or even whether you reveal
or not doesn't matter when someone has
that characteristic then you can utilize
that characteristic I know that's not
the best sounding word to talk about
like manipulating my wife's emotions
yeah but what I want to do is manipulate
her emotions to make her feel happy
about something the right not
necessarily a bad thing it's a good
thing so be cognizant when you're
dealing with other human beings look for
these things you see these things if you
take a step back if you don't take a
step back you'll never see them if you
can't detach when you tell your wife
something and you you you see that it
makes her Maddie if you can't detach if
you talking to an employee and you see
that they're getting frustrated and you
can't detach to try and figure out what
that is you're not gonna make any real
progress so yes a direct thing we'd like
to be or when people are direct to us
and makes things easier for us you know
but does lose weightweight who's the
weak on I retire whoever people who like
because here's the deal man
direct is a very a very blunt force tool
and not many people wield it well and
not many people receive it well yeah so
if you're one of these people is that
you all just look to be direct right
that's not good and very seldom do you
end up in situations where you can just
be direct with people you have to have
real strong built relationships we
people where you can just be that blunt
and direct with him now there are
methodologies where you can be direct
without being direct mmm you know you
can say things that are hey this is what
we need to get done right now you can
take an edge off of it yeah you can end
with the way you usually do that is by
taking ownership of what it is you're
trying to make happen so what I don't
say is like echo you need to get this
thing edited tonight yeah right I don't
do that I might say hey is there any
chance we could get this thing attitude
tonight because if we don't we're gonna
have a gap in releases which by the way
we haven't had and that's kind of a
thing yeah you see even you just kind of
know that it's a thing it is isn't it
we're there and all of a sudden you want
to edit that thing not because I told
you do because you want to keep the gaps
from be opening up sure so I was I was
directly telling you but I was indirect
so there's ways to do it but you got to
be careful with direct direct it takes a
long time to to hone the scalpel of
direct to where it just gets where you
want to cut and it doesn't leave any
collateral damage
not many people are good at it yeah very
few people are good at it sorry next
question junko and you know that makes
people mad what does the when you say
listen you can't just be you can't just
you can't just throw to people people
people want to say like there's the book
there's a book called radical frankness
or something like that that's not the
name of the book but it's something like
that it's like hey we just gonna tell
the total radical transparency or
something like that
and it's like we're just gonna tell the
truth all the time and we we can get
there but man it is work yeah and it's
not even work that has to be that that
necessarily is the best use no work
you know so yeah I just know I just know
I hear people all the time well you know
and people that's what people want me to
say I'll go and work with a company look
you know what we really need helpless we
just need to really learn to be direct
with each other yeah and what what they
really should be saying is what we need
to do is we need to learn to communicate
with each other be open about what
issues we have how to solve those
problems and be more tactful in our
discussions so that people are receptive
yeah because think about what I just
said if it's not just about me being
direct the more important the only way
that I can be direct is if I have set
you up in such a way that you or I've
built you in such a way that you're
receptive to my directness because me
being direct without you being receptive
it doesn't work and so often that's what
I see I see
hey I'm direct but but you're not
receptive it's it's game over yeah so
even if I'm direct I'm only 50% of the
solution because you have to be
receptive yeah what's easier when I when
I go indirect I become 90% of the
solution because I'm gonna get it into
your brain without resistance yeah so I
it's an easier it's easier up front of
me I'll just be direct yeah that's easy
up front cuz I just say echo you need to
get this stuff edited now that's direct
mm-hmm one of the chances of you being
receptive to that 50% yeah you know
whereas if I well let me rephrase that
in order for this to be effective you
have to be receptive to it yeah so I
only have 50% of the solution you have
the other 50% whereas if I say like I
said before you know hey echo we is
there any chance we can get this done
tonight because here's what's at stake
in it and I go indirect and I make that
idea and make your answer you're gonna
give me the answer I want I know it can
be edited tonight right I know that
it makes sense and so I'm gonna you're
actually gonna tell me I'm putting it
into you I'm giving you all you have to
do is just tell me and now I'm the one
that's receptive yes we can't oh that's
great that's great I'm glad so that's
something very important to talk about
if you want to talk about learning to be
direct with each other what you really
have to learn is how to be receptive to
directness that's the that's the long
pole in the tent and that's what
organizations are missing out on being
direct as easy yeah being direct is the
easiest thing in the world you tell
people what you think that's easy
yeah what's hard is setting the other
person up developing relationship so
that they're receptive to what you're
saying
I mean be careful you just play football
back in the day and mmm this new
quarterback came in what's weird is I
forget his name I'm just drawing a blank
right now but new young guy tall and he
had a gun if you're a quarterback and
you have a gun that's impressive you
know
yeah for sure means you throw far and
fast here's the thing though especially
when you knew you know and you have a
gun you're you're gonna show that gun
you know you're gonna be like when
you're playing you know when you're
warming up before practice and stuff
like that you're throwing anything
throwing it hard so this guy was
throwing it hard at me I was a receiver
and we're just state was just standing
and we were just standing there I wasn't
running around so he's throwing it and
it's hurting my hand to the point where
I couldn't catch some of them because
they were coming just too fast for you
know for that distance or whatever and
sure I was impressed with this guy's gun
but he won we'd wanna run routes and
stuff he'd still kind of do that I guess
maybe to impress the coaches you know
he's a young guy or whatever um and
here's the thing like people would miss
his balls they wouldn't catch them
because they're coming too hard they're
hurting your hands they're messing you
up you know so it makes it really hard
good a I get it it's great practice for
the receivers totally is but as far as
to effectively land a pass you know to
complete a pass right doesn't work like
this and we had this other quarter
longneck oh let me just stop you because
you may have just made
like the best analogies you've ever made
on this podcast that is it cool if that
if you can throw that thing direct but
if you're throwing it too hard and the
person's not ready to receive it right
not even not even to mention that you
might not be ready drew you might be
looking the other direction that hits
you in the back of the head yeah what
good is that direct comment it's zero
good it's not good
hurting your hands when you've tried it
receive it it hurts you yeah and you
don't want to hear anymore you want
anymore to be thrown at you
nope okay proceed as opposed to this
other quarterback who came in from
Stanford but your hard work is paying
off that's thanks
so this other quarterback came in at
quarterback make it anywhere did he make
the NFL he did not make it to that I
think oh so so the quarterback came and
his name is Tim Carey he came from like
a stamp for anything and he came in he
was the kind of the opposite actually
not the opposite because he had a guy he
could throw far and suffer but the way
he threw it was like it was like the
perfect pass like every distance had a
different velocity on it you know it was
like that kind where the next if he
would modulated there's so well he
modulated so well where Larry did the
volume for those chasis reckless oh yeah
mmm
everything and for them to get better he
would have to physically walk it and put
it in your hand it was like that good
when he'd come you know and when you
have them side by side oh man I want
that direct I want the finesse guy you
know but he did have a capability oh
thank you to the NFL um I may be ever
ever again he left Stanford to come to
your college um I forget why but I think
we're good it was a whole thing there
was a few Stanford guys they came yeah
that's interesting
yeah you guys from Stanford that came
two years ago didn't you yeah he was
doing it I want to say when we changed
coaching staffs there might have been
some Scouts connections maybe like some
relationships that were already there
even some of the coaches I think came
from that area I don't know I forget
that was a long time ago but nonetheless
yeah that's a way to check out sure so
there you go
Jaakko 13-year street cop here my old
man died when I was 10 it cut deep and I
grew up with no one having two boys of
my own now and loving to get after it on
the street I worry about the risk how do
i balance being a the spear with
ensuring I stay around for them so first
of all we have to recognize that there's
no way that you can ensure that you stay
around and in fact one day you will not
be around one day none of us will be
around that's the fact and that actually
doesn't matter what your job is and
there's all kinds of things regardless
your job whether you have a car accident
whether you have a heart attack whether
you have cancer or a plane crash or
random violence or some random accident
there's all different kind of ways to
die now you are correct that the the
death rate of cops is higher it's higher
than a normal civilian but what like
loggers construction workers they all
have a higher rates of death than a cop
roofers roofer if you're a roofer you
have a higher rate of death than a cop
any drivers anyone that drives for a
living
whether there are trucker or whether
they're literally a traveling salesman
they have a higher rate of death than
being being police so no matter what you
do there's a chance that you could get
you could die and I'll tell you what I
think about this sometimes in the
reverse of like what do you would it
what scares you about what your kids do
if your kids are engaging in activity
that could be dangerous
whether it's parachuting whether it's
rock climbing whatever like there's
things that your kids could do that they
could die and what you could do is not
allow them to do it wrap them in bubble
bubble wrap and not allow them to go
anywhere and guess what even if you do
that there's still a chance and you've
taken away you know their growth so you
can look at it the reverse as well that
there's some things that you're not
gonna be able to control and no matter
what you know your kid could you could
say I don't want my kid to join the
military and so they go to college and
what happens in college they get hit by
a drunk driver they like there's enough
bad things that could happen in either
one of those situations and same thing
with you and your job you could go get a
job doing something unless you get a job
that's just straight up you know in an
administrative situation with note with
very limited commute and very limited
driving then that might increase your
chances a little bit then but then you
you know then are you doing something
that you actually like to do so there's
your dilemma so what do you do in a
situation like this what you do is you
train and you prepare and you vigilant
and you take care of your sons obviously
and you would explain your job to them
and you explain to them why you train
hard and you explain to them why you're
willing to make a sacrifice to keep
others safe including them you you work
every day to keep them safe as well and
if you explain that to your sons they
will grow up with an understanding of
service and discipline and duty and
courage and honor and by the way if
something did happen to you the model
that you set for them would have massive
impact would have massive impact on them
and how they would live their lives and
I believe it would be actually a
positive impact sure would they miss you
absolutely sure would they wish more
than anything that you could be back yes
but would they recognize that their dad
made
this sacrifice yes they would would they
live to honor that sacrifice yes they
would so that's one thing you can do if
you want to keep that profession now if
that if you can't get around that if
that doesn't make sense which it's
understandable if you look at me and say
hey jock will I get it
I want my kids to be raised with honor
but I'd want to be there and that's more
important to me and if that's where if
that's where you end up then what you
have to do is plot out what another job
what another career is gonna be and like
I said then you have to make it doing
something that legitimately gets you
into a better better survival rate which
by the way outlaws just about every
outdoor job you could have so you're you
know you if you work in construction
nope that's not it
working as electrician no that's not it
working as a linemen nope that's not it
all those jobs all those outdoor jobs go
look at this statistics go Google death
rates in jobs and there's all kinds of
fishermen no forget about it you know
there's so many jobs that have a high
death rate where accidents happen so
what you're talking about going into the
life you're going into would be going
into would be an administrative job of
some kind and and if you think you can
do that and you think that'll be give
you the satisfaction that you want then
then it's a possibility think about it
but if you look at it and you think you
know what that's not for me then train
hard prepare build a great relationship
with your sons stay vigilant don't get
complacent ever and be aggressive I have
to throw that one in there
because in my opinion when when an
individual gets scared or gets hesitant
or gets overprotective of themselves I
believe they're in more danger not less
danger and more danger
so if you think that having kids having
your sons is making you less aggressive
and more scared I think you're at higher
risk so if you're gonna do the job you
do the job you get aggressive when you
do the job and if you can't then you got
you you might want to look and see if
there's other alternatives that are out
there the other thing I would say is
this how how often it like you're a
street cop you've been there for 13
years is there another department you
could go to is there some other way to
serve and and stay connected use your
experience in another in another way
maybe one area that has a little less
probability of getting killed again you
got to look if that's something you'd
really want to do so ultimately and I
tell this to people a lot is there's
only one person that can make this
decision and it's not me the only person
that can make this decision is you so
think through it be thoughtful you can
even talk about it with your boys
depending on how old they are but you
can talk about it with them explain to
them and you know see what they say you
know obviously there's one way that
conversation go hey would you guys be
sitting what you guys want me to die
right of course what are they gonna say
oh my gosh quit that job immediately we
don't want you to do that right so
you're gonna have to think of I don't
know what the ages of your kids are but
you have to think through that one
whether how you address it with them but
certainly I always look at it that
there's risk at everything you do you
might as well take risk doing something
that you love doing and that you know is
helping other people and you know
setting a good example for your boys and
if that doesn't make sense
cool find a nut find a different job
next question
I was young boy living in a foster home
and was sexually assaulted by my foster
father and sometimes other people over a
course of a couple years I was
eventually adopted and what had happened
to me was never discussed and I never
got help for it I was afraid of
everything
and eventually I played sports and I
school and felt less afraid went into
the Army and felt completely unafraid of
anything when I got out I got into a
long-term relationship I told my
then-girlfriend what had happened to me
she was the first person ever told about
this she convinced me to reach out to my
foster parents and I did and it was a
total disaster they kept my room were
all this bad stuff it happened exactly
the same as it was 20 years ago 20 years
prior when these horrors had occurred I
had my moment to confront this monster
that had done this to me and I failed I
used a word that he always said to me
which was I used a word that he always
said to me when he was assaulting me
he just said sometimes people change all
of a sudden I was a weak young boy again
and I couldn't fight back I left the
house and had serious self-doubt
eventually I became a cop and then a
detective and have faced all types of
bad people from junkies to murders I
even get full confessions out of child
rapists I'm sick to my stomach
afterwards it's terrible terrible to
hear what these animals do my question
is this recently the past has come back
with a vengeance I can't get through a
short time maybe an hour too without
thinking about the past and my failure
the only time I have peace is when I
absolutely destroy myself working out I
consider it punishing myself and feel
better when I do it how can I stop this
or at least manage it better
so this is I mean obviously a horrible
situation and you know horrible that you
had to live through this and that any
kid or anyone any human would have to go
through this as far as how you can
manage this better I'm gonna go a little
bit here so one of the blocks of
training that we go through in a seal
platoon is called close quarters combat
and this is the training you're in a
thing called the kill house its
ballistic walls there's targets in there
you're moving around dynamically you're
shooting live fire ammunition there's
people six inches away from you you're
taking really close shots there's a lot
of pressure in there there's a lot of
details a lot of standard operating
procedures and safety procedures that
you have to follow there's a lot of
process it's like do you need to go left
or right is that a good guy or a bad guy
cuz you have to identify the targets
should you move or should you stay how
do you communicate that you need to move
should you shoot or should you not shoot
at a target and so there's all these
things going on when you enter a room
all these things that you have to go
through all these steps that you have to
take all these procedures that you have
to follow all these decisions that you
have to make and it all happens in a
split second and so in a kill house the
training cadre is actually above you
above the it's not a normal house the
the the rooms have what we call catwalks
above them so the cadre can be up above
you in the catwalks and they're walking
around and they're watching you very
closely it's like watching a football
game on TV you're seeing it from like
the perfect view above the person and
they're in the room with you but they're
not in your way at all because they're
up on the catwalk so what happens is
when a room entry happens there's a lot
of you catch a lot of critique from
the people in the catwalk and they'll
say you know you could you could have
done this or you could done that or you
could have you could move laughter you
should have pushed forward or there's
you know you even better if you've done
this other thing so there's all these
different things and when my cadre was
running it you know that's what we do
that's what happened to me when I was
cadre that's what I would do that's what
everyone does and at some point I kind
of realized that all that stuff is good
and I get it like you got to get people
to run the procedures correctly but in a
certain point what I would tell that
like after a guy was kind of beat down
like he just couldn't get something
right or he would yield blood bunch of
people would jump on him about a
decision that he made or a movement that
he made or whatever and I'm not talking
about safety thing because the safety
thing is different I'm talking about a
tactical decision and when you walk into
her and there's a bunch of tactical
decisions you can make and and if
there's ten if there's five different
decisions that you could make when you
walk into a room there's something that
there's you know there's one way of
doing it that would be like really clean
one would be a little bit less one might
be just as clean as the first one but
it's a different attitude there's all
these different decisions that you could
make you know it's like just a multitude
of ways that you could react because
that's what this question is how you
reacted in this situation and eventually
as I would see this with an individual I
would eventually I what I would tell
guys is listen you did what you did you
did what you did that's what you did
that's the decision that you made at the
time and you know what there's different
ways you could have done it you don't
like the way you did it I don't like the
way you did it someone on one of the
other cadre members doesn't like the way
you did it it doesn't what what I'm
saying it doesn't really matter first of
all you can't take it back you can't go
back and undo it and by the way you
don't get to rehearse these things to a
point where you get to do
is perfectly because you won't be able
to do that if you rehearsed a move in a
room that you had seen before and you
rehearsed it 10 times that's not that's
a totally different game right if I
already know what the room consists of
and I'm gonna rehearse and choreograph
the entire movement that's a different
game that's not decision-making that's
just that's just rote memorization we're
not talking about that we're talking
about how did you react and what you did
is what you did and you did it for a
reason what you saw in front of you you
made this decision for a reason maybe
like you know you saw a threat when
there wasn't one there or you lost
situational awareness or you rushed you
went too fast you tried to rush and all
those things can kind of can kind of
trip you up but that's what you did and
you did what you did and you can't take
it back so instead of everyone sitting
there saying you should have done this
and you should have done that let's do
this let's see what we can learn from it
let's see why you did what you did let's
see why you made that decision because
once we know why you did something now
we have something that we can work with
we have something that we can improve
upon that is what I think you need to do
in this situation and really when anyone
makes a mistake or has a reaction that
they don't like you can't worry you
can't continue to worry about something
that has already transpired what you
have to do is you have to look at it and
say what can I learn from it what can I
take from this and and how can I take
this mistake and make me better so you
could look at this why did you do that
right maybe you did it because you
didn't want to open up these old wounds
maybe you did it because you would have
you confronting this individual would
have caused more drama and that more
that drama you were you at that moment
you assessed and said you know what this
drama isn't worth it
maybe you protected yourself from more
drama and that was your instinct
and maybe if you would have started
confronting this guy and going crazy the
you know who knows what could have
happened and maybe it could have taken a
turn for the worse we don't know what
the outcome was we know that you weren't
happy with your decision understandable
but we don't even know what the other
decisions would have led to so where
you're actually getting bogged down and
and distraught about something that you
don't even know if it was a good
decision or a bad decision it feels like
it was a bad decision but you don't know
what the outcomes the other decisions
even were so you can't change the
outcome of what happened in the past you
can't do it but what you can do is you
can grow from it
that's what you can do you can learn
from it you can actually take that
scenario and you can mentally replay it
in your head and you can figure out if
possibly there would have been or could
have been a better outcome or maybe that
that outcome that you had wasn't that
bad or maybe it leads somewhere else we
don't know yet but that's that's where
you are at right now you can't change
the outcome of something that has
occurred in the past now I'm gonna I'm
gonna throw a little dichotomy at you
right now and I'm gonna say something
that's a little bit it might be a little
bit hard to understand I'm gonna try and
talk my way through it because while you
can't change the past what you can
change is you can absolutely change the
way that the past is perceived so let me
give you a detached example just another
example if you had an individual someone
gets fired from a job they get fired
from their job and when they get fired
from the job it what it does is it their
confidence goes down and they get
depressed and they decide they're not
gonna even apply for a new job because I
don't even know if I deserve it get a
new job and they sit around and
eventually they they go
apply for kind of like a lesser job and
you know who knows maybe they start
drinking to relieve some of their
depression and now they're late and now
they they end up on a downward spiral we
would look at them being fired as
something that destroyed them and ruined
her life that's how we would perceive it
hey the individual got are they they
were they weren't doing fine then they
got fired and now they lost their
confidence I got depressed they started
drinking they didn't apply for jobs and
now their life is totally different in
as a bad place we would perceive that
them getting fired did that to them but
if this if that person if a person got
fired from their job and in instead it
was like a wake-up call for them and
they immediately applied for a bunch of
other jobs and maybe they didn't get
those because they'd just been fired but
maybe they took a lesser job a lower
paying job but they got in there and
they had realized they had made a
mistake and they started getting after
that like they've never gotten after it
before they started working as hard as
they possibly could and got promoted and
then got promoted again and just
dominated in those positions and when he
even harder and dominated even more and
eventually took over the whole company
and this isn't crazy this isn't too
far-fetched this can happen but if that
happened that same incident the firing
of this individual would be perceived in
a totally different way it would be
perceived as a catalyst that changed
their life for the better and there are
all kinds of examples like that in the
world the past can't be changed but the
past can change you for the better or it
can change you for the worse and my
question is why not make it for
the better why not make the past change
you for the better you hear the term you
hear the term narrative thrown around
these days especially like in political
circles you'll hear it on the news that
narratives they're created in the
political arena and what the narrative
does is it supports an overarching aim
or an overarching value or an
overarching goal that's what that's what
that's the way people use the term
narrative right now but I'm not talking
about that type of political narrative
what I'm saying here is that you
actually write the narrative of what
happened in your past I'm not talking
about a fabrication of it I'm talking
you get the right the narrative of where
it takes you you get to write the
narrative you get to write the reality
of where you end up you get to write it
you get to control it so what I'm saying
is control it get control of that
narrative take control of that narrative
that's that horrible story in your past
ends the way that you want it to end
you control the narrative you control
that story so make that story good make
that story
epic make that story and make the
direction that your life goes make it a
relic
and that's how I think you can get
control or maybe handle better some of
that horrific stuff that you've been
through and I think that's all I've got
for tonight
so echo Charles speaking of being heroic
myth
speaking of controlling our own
narrative of the past of the present of
the future what can we do to write that
heroic story for ourselves yes well
let's start with the path we're stay on
the path we're gonna get on the path
we're gonna be on the path so part of
the path is jiu-jitsu of course like
we've said many times you're gonna need
a geet what get I got to interview the
other day cool and the guy kind of sets
up this kind of big question sure
he says you know in this day and age and
I'm not gonna do injustice he was a
great question it was a nice question I
get it yeah and I'm not gonna do it as
eloquently as he did it but the question
was about you know in this day and age
when man and it was one of those like
men like type things in this day and age
when men are you know can be isolated
and can get depressed and don't have
meaning and all this stuff right what do
we you know what do you recommend to men
that feel that way that feel isolated
and feel alone and feel depressed and
feel like they don't have meaning in
their life I feel like they can't
connect with anyone and I was like oh
cool yeah go to jujitsu classes and I
felt bad because they wanted me to give
like the big you have found thing about
where the find meaning in your life and
what I said was yet start training
jiu-jitsu because the thing that he
grabbed me with is like oh you know you
want you you want to have a goal you
won't have meaning you want to connect
with people you don't want to be alone
loneliness and all this stuff I'm like
yeah
go change it to all this problems get
solved right there dude right all of a
sudden you got people to hang out with
you got a mission
you got Fitness going on you got meaning
it's all kinds of good stuff going on
yeah so go strain some jujitsu is what
I'm saying yeah a good place to start
that's one of those deals too with them
like you leave jiu-jitsu with something
not just fitness and better health and
stuff you leave with like a skill yeah I
just feeds into you your whole soul
especially man the manliness thing oh
man the capability to defeat another man
yeah we'll have to see we'll check in
with some of our females because when I
talk to our female jiu-jitsu
practitioners they might even feel a
little bit better because they get to
like choke men no doubt about it so yeah
yeah so so what we're saying basically
is try training some jujitsu look is it
a cure-all yeah a little bit yeah for
certain people in certain situations I
think yeah I think so I have a feeling
when I leave jujitsu after I get done
training hmm then I feel good yes sir
just think about that just think about
think if I gave you a pill that said oh
if you just take this pill you'll feel
good you just you're just round Li
you'll just feel good yeah but there's
no in fact the only side effects are
that you'll be a little healthier and
you'll have a you'll have a quality
skill that you can utilize in the real
world just take this pill would you take
the pill who wouldn't sure what I'm
saying is you get to go to jiu-jitsu
yeah is it harder than taking a pill
sure but is it harder to eat a steak or
eat a pill steak technically technically
it's order to eat a steak would you
rather do eat a steak I'd rather he just
take and I'd rather change you Jitsu
than take a pill me too so get on that
train that jujitsu training kid Han
legit used to train and you're gonna do
ghee and nogi so what kind of ghee to
get you get the best key question and I
realized I like dramatically
interrupting you sometimes good
I did get to something so piggy origin
yes Georgian main calm this is where you
can get your geek many different options
they come out with new ones is pretty
cool
Pete's very creative with that stuff
yeah I encourage people that creativity
and keep it on that level as well anyway
don't encourage him not on I encourage
all encourage and compliment as well so
yes origin main community you can get a
rash car too if you want
also some shirts on there some joggers
and whatnot supplements as well what
about just for what if you were gonna go
see a movie can you wear your G to a
movie
oh well no okay can you wear your key to
a dinner date with your wife no but no
you can't so what do we do with origin
then alright
yes well the good news is we got some
American denim we got jeans and jeans
yeah or Jean jeans boom yeah those are
good man those those came out really
really good I think those are gonna go
go places yeah this one I will give Pete
some leeway for his creativity well
because he did this thing with the yoke
of the jeans you know the yoke is no
it's a little piece of it's like right
below the waistband and there's two
types of different yokes you can have
reverse yoke or or regular yoke I guess
it's called anyways it's it makes it so
that the pants fit a certain way and
then he lined up the tops of the pockets
with the reverse yoke which means that
they're slanted a little bit like the
old school Vietnam pockets okay so
anyways that's tails going on gathering
that you're starting to appreciate
Pete's fashion sense that's what I'm
gathering to crazy I'm saying
occasionally no no no no here's the deal
the pockets because they're at a little
angle they're easier to get your hand in
and out of which what I'm saying is
there is a functionality because if it
didn't
functional I wouldn't be talking about
it right now no because we don't talk
about things like that but they look
built this what I'm saying I think you
certain appreciate that on and I'm
saying is I think I think Pete did it
not for functionality I think Pete did
it because it looked cool and then I
commend his creativity because not
because it looked cool but because it
provides a level of functionality that
does not previously exist in jeans
anywhere so I agree with you I agree
with the whole deal the whole gig and
man yeah
yeah those are good American get them by
the way all made in America yes the
cotton is made in America grown what
about the things that you put you fasten
the um we are waist with the buttons
yeah the buttons we're done since
Compton just look at a picture of the
button that's enough to be like all sold
begin with they're pretty dope the very
dope actually plus we got supplements as
you were just about to say yes
supplements important supplement not
this mega mast was that one old schooner
the big number unless it's not like that
well I guess kinda cuz monk
is additional Pro a cleaner clean
protein
slow-release Braden did a really good
but let's face it it just days god yes
well it doesn't just a shit it tastes
good that might be what's that word that
might be the number one priority there
was a number one benefit the fact that
it's the best protein you can actually
get as awesome - yeah cool well you can
eat a steak if you want protein as well
so there's very scared always eat a
steak that's the problem
sometimes you're like on the go
sometimes you got to get sometimes it's
you got work to do yeah time to eat a
steak sometimes you just want to dessert
- let's face it
come on bro let's face it so boldly
facing it there you go
so yeah some oak is like that but the
Sun the joint warfare krill oil these
are for your joints keep your joints in
the game if you're for real getting
after it like especially in the gym and
doing jujitsu man those the the joint
warfare in the crude oils getting out
and keep you in the game big tubs can
help you out a lot I'm huge time as we
say don't forget about the warrior kid
milk as well yeah
which is which is tasty and why not feed
your kids something that's actually
gonna be good for them instead of
feeding them literal poison yeah gummy
bears yeah sugar let's just and
discipline as well if you want some
cognitive enhancing elements infused
into your brain get some discipline
that's a good one
get yourself some chocolate tea as well
yeah that's if you want to have a
massive deadlift in excess of 8,000
pounds Jack yeah
also it's certified organic so that's
something also web the store it's called
Chacko store
you can get the tea on the store too we
have the tea on the store but also on
the store jon stewart calm this is where
you can get shirts you want to represent
on the path discipline equals freedom
even get after it you know simple stuff
I chose quality shirts over cheap
quantity sure so when you get this shirt
should be as it should be right so if
you get this shirt and you recognize
that dang this this could very well be
my favorite shirt just to wear just the
fit in the feel of the shirt I won't be
surprised in fact I'd be surprised if
it's not that's my opinion
nonetheless this good stuff on there's
rash guards on there some hats flex fit
and snapback trucker hats some hoodies
lightweight and heavyweight some good
stuff on there anyway if you want
something get something it is jackal
store.com also don't forget to subscribe
to this podcast if you want to go ahead
and smash the subscribe button over know
the last one last one
all right no more me so if you want to
arrive you can click the subscribe
button
yeah well I guess I guess if you're
gonna remind someone to do something in
regards to subscribing it'd be more on
the YouTube thing to do the notification
bell if they want to be notified because
that's not just a given when you
subscribe I don't know some people might
not know that
saying okay I'm definitely more person
that did not know that well there you go
um so yeah subscribe whatever Twitter or
not Twitter sorry stitcher Google Play
iTunes that kind of stuff yeah yeah
also don't forget the word keep podcast
three new releases yep 24 25 and 26 boom
including an interview with John Bozak
the illustrator the Gerar of pictures of
all the orchid books including Mikey and
the Dragons anyway yeah very interesting
on that one especially if you're into
any kind of creative thing a kind of
demonstrates it or talks about the
process and the frustration it's good I
actually liked it a lot also where a kid
soap Irish Oaks ranch dot-com is where
you can get Jocko soap trooper soap all
made by warrior kid 8 in in the United
States by the way does he have some kind
of model or anything with that yeah like
I'm it's a slogan was its slogan stay
clean sorry about I'll say it all like
go crazy like you would but bus stay
clean simple to the point right yeah all
good I was not impressed with time I
know your job they're doing the best
they can anyway like I mentioned we have
a youtube channel as well chocolate gas
YouTube channel if you were interested
in the video version of this uh this
year situation and some excerpts on
there some enhanced excerpts on there
too if you want to look at them it's
good psychological warfare it's out
there iTunes Google Play mp3 get it
don't forget about the visual versions
of psychological warfare from flipside
canvas comm which is run by my brother
Dakota Meyer mm-hmm
you might want to check that one out as
well yeah if discipline equals freedom
art yeah yeah we we have posters right
which is cool like you hang them in your
gym and whatever but it's like one two
maybe three levels higher than the
poster is like you know can you hang on
your wall in your home in your office
clearly you could go I'm gonna put these
things up they are legit and we got some
warrior Kid posters up art as well
because I'm not just posters they like
they're like yeah also on it on it calm
/ chuckle go there kick on it this is
where you can get what kettlebells like
fitness stuff so you know some cool
supplements some greens some food items
you know this is where I get my
kettlebells actually yeah like pretty
much all my home gym stuff aside from
like the dumbbell sets they get from on
it all of it go in there on it calm
slash chocolate get something and got
some books too I've written a bunch of
them way the warrior kid where there's a
will number that's number three of that
book that is live so get that for your
kid also get the way the warrior kid one
and way of the warrior kid two which is
called marks mission these books are
good and these are the books I wish I
had when I was a kid they would have
just put me on the path at a younger age
Mikey and the dragons you can order that
one now as well that is for a little bit
younger age maybe three four five six
through seventy this one equals freedom
Field Manual all the little questions
that you want to ask me about everything
our answer is answered in that book the
discipline it was freedom Field Manual
how to get after it the audio version is
not on audible it's on iTunes it's on
Amazon music it's on Google Play other
mp3s and those are questions that you
might have about life about my personal
operating system if you have questions
about leadership check out extreme
ownership and the dichotomy of
leadership I referenced them both today
and I reference them all the time
written by me and my brother lave babban
about the experiences we had overseas
now you can take those experiences and
apply them to the leadership in your
life and world we also have a salon
front which is our leadership
consultancy we solve problems through
leadership you can go to a salon front
comm for details on that if you want to
get some additional training online you
go to EF online.com and that's where we
have all the ash LAN Front instructors
Jeane classes online interactive classes
check that one out if you want to go
more granular and then we have the
muster which is a conference gathering a
leadership gathering the next one is in
Denver September 19th and 20th and then
in Sydney Australia December 4th and 5th
check extreme ownership comm for details
all of the musters have sold out in
these will too so get there early and of
course we have EF overwatch where we are
taking spec ops and combi combat
aviation leaders and placing them into
civilian companies that need leader ship
EF overwatch comm if you want to hire
someone from Special Operations or your
former Special Operations and you would
like to work in the civilian sector go
to EF overwatch comm follow the
instructor and so we will hook it up and
if you feel like you want to cruise with
us just a little bit more you can find
us both on the interwebs on Twitter on
Instagram and on the vase book EKKO is a
deco Charles and I am at Jocko willing
and thanks to all of you that make this
podcast possible first those of you in
the armed services who put your honor
and Duty above yourselves and protect
freedom around the world and to all the
police officers and law enforcement to
the firefighters the paramedics the EMTs
the dispatchers the correctional
officers the Border Patrol Secret
Service and all the other first
responders each of you do the same you
place the welfare of others above the
welfare of yourself in order to keep us
safe so thanks for what you do and the
rest of you that are out there thanks
for the support that you all give us you
are the
fuel that keeps this train moving
literally we appreciate it and also
remember this no matter what happened in
the past you control the narrative you
write the story that you want to write
you give yourself the role that you want
make your thoughts in that story filled
with discipline and make your actions
make them nothing short of heroic
and then step out into the world and get
after it then until next time this is
echo and Jocko out